on a préféré mettre un piano qu'une
armoire non ou un dressing est-ce que
est-ce que vous savez pourquoi
c'est ce que j'ai cru comprendre vous
êtes limite acétique en la matière c'est
c'est quoi ces trois t-shirts 4 non mais
c'est vrai j'aime voir les gens bien
habillés c'est élégant c'est beau je
peux regarder la mode comme comme un
spectacle ou comme de la création j'aime
bien
me mettre un bon costard si je veux une
soirée un festival mais dans mon
quotidien j'ai quasiment un uniforme
mais je pourrais avoir j'ai d'ailleurs
quatre t-shirts bleus quatre t-shirts
blancs quatre t-shirt noir et 3 Jean et
donc j'ai rien d'autre et un pull bleu
et un pull noir mais ça ne m'intéresse
pas mais je voilà je juge pas les gens
qui sont dans la fashion dans la
façonnerie il y a l'ordre qui va avec on
est limite maniaque maniaque c'est pas
le mot mais
en plus
on dit
ouais peut-être maniaque non c'est pas
ouais obsession alors on n'est pas mal
obsessionnel pardon mais c'est on a
pas voilà oui parce que vous arrivez
même en avance au rendez-vous oui
j'arrive en fait c'est une théorie à
l'ancienne je vais vous dire ça mais
j'ai l'impression que pour être à
l'heure il faut arriver en avant
[Rires]
il faut arriver en avance et puis et
puis se mettre dans le dans le
rendez-vous et arriver à l'heure
vraiment détendu quoi et je suis assez
intolérant avec les gens qui sont en
retard je te passe est-ce que j'ai cru
comprendre une dynamique dans le dans le
rendez-vous la rencontre qui est
déséquilibrée il y avait pas une
meilleure idée créer une ambiance
ailleurs tout ça là c'était tout était
naturel et pour nous ça aurait été
difficile d'aller ailleurs pour bien sûr
avant notre bonne idée bon au début nous
on a paniqué on a vu c'est cette
organisation énorme on a paniqué mais il
a su franchement nous
nous calmer
nous donner des petits exemples pour
jouer il a été formidable garde
pense à nous pour le prochain film
attention on a envie de continuer avec
toi
bravo
c'est très émouvant c'est super
le
l'humour vraiment c'est un langage dans
ma famille mon père c'est pas un comique
ma mère non plus mais c'est un langage
c'est une manière de dire les choses là
je le vois encore plus quoi c'est
c'est beaucoup de pudeur c'est mon père
s'adresser rarement à moi aussi
longtemps je crois que je vous remercie
Nathalie d'ailleurs je crois que c'est
la plus longue déclaration de moi mon
père c'est un taiseux comme on dit
j'aime pas il vous apporte quoi ce
personnage ce qu'il m'apporte d'ailleurs
pour être tout à fait honnête je
m'interroge sur la perception
aujourd'hui avec ce qu'on vit sur le
genre
l'homosexualité
le féminisme
la lutte en tout cas pour l'égalité pour
tout ça je m'interroge sur
quel aurait été la perception en tout
cas de
cette de ce personnage
qui est quand même un hymne à la
tolérance mais qui disait des choses
quand même j'arrive pas à savoir si ce
serait reçu de manière
sereine mais la chose qui m'intéresse
c'est le pont que je peux faire avec mon
film c'est qu'il y a une quête
d'identité
c'est assez lié pour moi
en fait en vrai j'aurais préféré pas
préférer non pas préféré j'aurais aimé
j'aurais aimé être un pianiste de jazz
mais
[Musique]
merci Gad il y avait un peu de
Casablanca évidemment vous avez entendu
Casablanca non je me suis planté